every outfit it's like I don't like it
but if you had put it on Kendall Jenner
I would have liked it people say what
you want about Kendall like I don't
think there has ever been a Met Gala
where she wasn't in a top five when I'm
judging someone's look I try to think if
Kendall wore it would I like it yeah her
outfit last night was literally top five
but like I could see someone else
it went out without pants to the Met
Gala Jennifer Lopez and Ralph Lauren
it's like what if Kendall were wearing
it
stunning
Doja cat Perfection yeah I don't think
everyone could pull this off if everyone
if other people showed up like a cat
with the Cindy Lou Who prosthetic nose
it's perfect Kendall could have showed
up like a cat yes Salma Hayek I didn't
see her until now this
is terrible
yeah I would say it's not great like if
Kendall wore it still I think I would
hate it I would have questions I would
question it even if it was questioning
it with Kendall